one of the words that we commonly use as
Puerto Ricans is ojala ojala
Mira Mira way para la mañana ojala me
Paseo halakha tsubasa right ojala comes
from Allah
hopefully Miss Puerto Rico be watching
this too and we'll kind of go ahead and
give her response to the tweets she has
some really nasty hurtful things to say
it hurts but we're gonna give her some
love for me it's not too much different
than what happened after 9/11 you see
the same hate to say
you
hiroshima on a light switch hiroshima
with a light switch the weapon would be
mobile shooting concentrated doses of
radiation on unsuspected targets who
would die within two weeks among the
potential target sources say Muslims and
President Obama took a Bible and he
covered it Bible who cooked and there's
uncle Topher Tilton : Eden ever woken up
asaji sky highlights hysterical tossed
on but also vestige of Norma and Marlin
in sky kata Hobart also adapted to bible
for like an immense upstart marcelina
for the standing lava that's had to come
right now if you haven't already peace